wow
that was fast
this was like this big
less than two minutes ago this is the
eight sleep pod pro one of the top rated
smart beds on the market right now and
what exactly makes a smart bed so smart
this one comes equipped with sensor
technology an app that gathers sleep
data and a water hub for temperature
control i feel overwhelmed already
that's why you're here
this is dr wendy troxel she's a clinical
psychologist specially trained in sleep
medicine which basically means she's an
expert in all things sleep for the past
16 years or so i've spent most of my
waking hours thinking about and studying
sleep and treating individuals and
couples who present with sleep related
issues so then who better to test this
the eight sleep pod pro i'm a bit of a
skeptic honestly when it comes to smart
beds and overly fancy
sort of technology in general when it
comes to the bed and the bedroom let's
see if this smart bed can win her over
and help us decide is a smart bed really
smarter for your sleep
[Music]
spending more time at home during the
pandemic has led a lot of people to
upgrade their bedrooms buying mattresses
that incorporate technology to improve
the quality of their sleep that's why
we're testing the 8 sleep pod pro but
why did we choose this smart bed a few
reasons
it has the most common smart bed
features sleep tracking and temperature
control but it also has a smart alarm
which silently wakes you up with chest
level vibration and gradual temperature
change it's also considered a mid-range
smart bed with the king size running
about thirty five hundred dollars smart
beds can cost anywhere from fifteen
hundred to over one hundred thousand
dollars i have to say i am completely
naive to the whole smart bed experience
i have never slept on one first dr
troxell assessed how easy it is to set
up the bed i did not know that it was
going to be a bed in a box it says this
is 80 pounds we were able to hire movers
which is very helpful these are heavy
boxes
while eight sleep doesn't offer white
glove service you can video call one of
their product experts to help with setup
hi how's it going good thanks for
meeting with us the setup itself i have
to say was a bit daunting and it felt
very medicalized to me you're going to
want to snake it through in the mid so
like down behind the mattress i mean the
fact that there's a tube coming out of
my bed
kind of rubbed me the wrong way a little
bit
so this was kind of cool first it asked
me
what side of the bed i sleep on then i
can also invite my partner
with the help of the tech support from
eight sleep it went relatively very
smoothly it was not instantaneous by any
means and after 90 minutes it'll be
quiet and perfect and ready to use next
dr troxell reviewed the bed for comfort
she and her husband slept on it for
three nights you know doesn't have any
of the other bells and whistles in terms
of contouring um or things like that
that other smart beds have
but it is certainly comfortable my
husband probably preferred the firmness
of the mattress more than i do comfort
is an entirely subjective experience and
this is why some smart beds not this one
do have individualized um firmness
preferences i did notice at that at
times in the night it was quite cool and
then in the morning when i was waking up
it warmed up because that's how i had
set my preferences and and i enjoyed
that finally dr troxell assessed the
effectiveness of the bed's sleep
tracking technology well according to
this app last night i was a perfect
sleeper i got a hundred on my sleep
score but to be honest with you i didn't
get a good night of sleep
this is the noise that we are currently
hearing i have no idea why this was
really disruptive to my sleep in fact i
know that i was awake
for
at least 30 minutes in the middle of the
night we did have to do
a re-priming of the hub today so
hopefully that may have resolved the
noise issue the noise that was virtually
non-existent last night but when i
looked at the metrics more closely i saw
that there were clearly errors in how
they were scoring my sleep you do have
the opportunity to edit your metrics and
i did so this morning by indicating that
i wasn't even trying to fall asleep
until about a half hour after the bed
had measured me sleeping and that i also
woke up about a half an hour before i
actually got out of bed so after trying
out the smart bed does dr troxel think
it's worth the 3 500 price tag i'm going
to give this mattress overall 3 star
rating i did enjoy the temperature
control feature and for partners who
share a bed i think this feature of
having a non-noise alarm is really nice
and the third thing i liked about the
bed was the technology support we
received now in terms of the cons every
time my husband moved i could not only
feel the mattress itself shifting but i
could also feel the
fabric in the mattress cover that would
shift as well the other thing that i was
not particularly pleased about was the
overall setup now the third downside was
the accuracy of the metrics i can tell
you from my own data that these metrics
were not entirely accurate an important
caveat of my review is that i only
tested this bed over three nights so my
experience of the bed may very likely
change over time eight sleep said it
takes about one week for the pod to
acclimate to your body and the sleep
fitness scores become more reflective of
your sleep quality the more you use it
with regard to the noise from the hub a
spokesperson said it typically occurs
when there is still air in the system
and all the unit needs is another round
of priming
where do you plug it in
that's a good question
a bed that plugs in but that's that's
not a watercolor supply
[Music]
i do have a phd
[Music]